so
yeah so this is actually the first time
that i'm talking about this uh to the to
the outside world so it will be very
exciting to see how it goes and what
kind of kind of feedback we get
so
yeah so i'm not going to belabor
introduction about a background about
kobit 19 because i assume that most of
you haven't been living under a rock for
the last uh three years so you so you
know way too much about it
so what i will stress about the um
about the disease though is that
it we do know that it's sort of
multi-organ disease uh the but the
primary organ that it seems to be
affecting is the lung
and
even though we've been very good uh very
successful at uh curtailing uh the sort
of uh the disease thanks to to the
vaccine development which in my my
opinion at least has been uh frankly uh
mind-blowing uh we still sort of know
relatively little about sort of
the underlying uh sort of
mechanisms of the disease product
progression and in particular
we have very poor ability to sort of
predict
uh which patients
that have the disease that are sort of
going to go really downhill and have a
really bad course
versus the ones that are going to
recover just fine so
having a better understanding of what's
happening at the cellular molecular
level uh has has a chance of helping us
being able to better predict those types
of things and could also result in in
sort of new treatments
uh so
yeah so a very brief background is sort
of about what we know about uh the
cobin 19 so it's caused by the sars kobe
2 virus
which binds to the ace2 receptors and
the main mode of entry is through the
airways the upper airways in particular
where this h2 receptor is highly
expressed so so that's how uh how most
people who get the who get the infection
uh how it starts uh so what happens
after that is uh sort of considerably
less is known so this paper uh as shown
here came out last year in nature so
there they did
uh sort of high throughput mass
cytometry uh they looked at lung tissue
from from a number of donors uh both uh
who had had covid and and those who who
didn't have covid
and they sort of
they looked at some 30 odd markers at
sort of very very high throughput and
they were able to sort of characterize
uh the the cell type compositions uh
that that these people that people had
in the lung so the sort of the main
take-home message that that
they saw here was that
these people seemed to have to a large
extent they had fibrosis and they had
coagulation um
problems
problem dysregulation the coagulatory
pathways
they also had a huge expansion of the
immune compartment uh the sort of
hyperinflammatory signal
and uh one of the things that they
highlighted was this sort of a big
increase in sort of mesenchymal cells
and and fibroblasts would be consistent
with the fibrosis phenotype and and this
was sort of uh confirmed here in this
sort of
uh
this sort of spatial uh staining here
where you can sort of see the
the fibrosis phenotype in the late
covalent patients
so what we what we have been doing is
really to build on this this type of
work uh but with instead of using mass
cytometry we've been using a spatial
transcriptomics uh platform so thanks a
lot to shayam who introduced uh you to a
lot of uh
the ins and outs of spatial
transcriptomics so what we wanted to do
here uh so we we used the nanostring
platform uh which i'll be telling you
more about in a second which
unfortunately you need these type of
references of single cell or single
nucleus uh nucleotide and
nucleus rnac for in order to use
and then once you've combined those two
data we can sort of look at the
different combinations of cell types and
try to understand something about the
progress of the disease
so
we use this nanostring geomics platform
uh which has the nice feature that it it
it contains about 18 000 probes
uh to target different uh species of rna
so that means that effectively
transcription-wide you can profile the
whole transcriptome
what you do is that you you these probes
are sort of hybridized um
on the on the tissue
and then you clean them and then you uh
you get these barcode tags that you can
sequence and and that gives you a
readout of the amount of expression uh
for each of these different uh probes
in one of these regions of interest that
you're profiling
uh so as i said the the advantages that
we have nearly transcription-wide uh the
downside is that this is not single
server resolution uh the estimate is it
would be that you sort of have
on the order of a few hundred cells
captured for each uh for each of these
probes
sorry in each region of interest
so uh in order to to be able to uh make
use of the data uh what we have to do is
that we have to deconvolute uh these
these signals and and to do that we we
need single cell our nasa data so uh so
we need a big single solar and asic data
that we can combine and then we have the
the two different conditions uh the cova
19 lungs and and the
and the controls
and and then we can sort of uh try to uh
tease out the differences between them
and once we have that we can sort of try
to understand differences in cell type
composition
and also
sell co-localizations
and interactions which i unfortunately
won't get to today
so fortunately
there has been a lot of work done in the
field of single cellular nasik with
regards to to kobe 19. so
building this kind of lung
reference atlas based on single cell
data uh
there there's a lot a lot of material to
that we can use here are two of the
papers um
that have have come out recently that we
used
uh in total uh we had 15 different
studies that we put together
gave us over 600 000 cells so if any one
of you who have worked on sort of doing
the sort of integration of
large data sets we'll know that this is
quite the labor of love
so big shout out to alike the postdoc at
imperial who did who spirited this work
of the integration
uh so these uh
these
oh these 600 000 cells came from about
150 patients of sort of uh some of them
with uh coping 19 and some of them
healthy
and this umap uh sort of shows it shows
you the overlap uh so all the cell types
and they're sort of colored by red is
covered and blue is healthy and those
are the colors that we'll be using
throughout this presentation
so
uh after we had
sort of done all this merging uh we
ran unsupervised clustering and we were
able to sort of identify these four main
categories the immune cells epithelial
cells endothelial cells and stromal
cells
but we also obviously also had more sort
of fine-grained annotation within each
of these clusters and you can sort of
see here
that we were able to sort of assign very
nice market genes uh to these clusters
so overall we're pretty convinced that
this is a very high quality uh reference
atlas and and it is
to our knowledge the sort of the largest
such atlas that has been been compiled
uh to date
uh so uh one of the things that we did
with this uh was to uh look at sort of
compare the the uh covid and and the
controls
and so for that we use this method
called milo and uh it's sort of it's a
neighborhood analysis uh uh in within
the
uh within the proximity graph and and
the in the gene expression space and so
what you can sort of see here uh
confirms what was sort of already known
that we have sort of big increase in the
immune cells and the stromal cells
uh within the um
uh coca-19 patients uh but at the same
time a loss of epithelial cells
and and this is sort of summarized here
uh where you can sort of very nicely see
that you have this uh
big d enrichment of the 81 and 82 cells
uh in in in the covid compared
compared to the controls and also big
increases in in
fibroblasts and immune cells
uh so
but the main purpose of this was of
course to be able to use the spatial
data so before i get into the spatial
data i need to tell you that in addition
to sort of extracting these samples and
profiling them using and this nanostring
technology we also had pathologists look
at each of these samples and sort of
score them using sort of established
criteria uh and
and
they have sort of four different
categories uh in terms of damage uh so
they're called known as press e dad m
and o dad so edad is the least severe
and odd is the most severe here
so
for this study
we had
33 different donors we had between 5 and
10
rois regions of interest that were
selected from each of the donors and
then profiled using using the nano
string so in total we have 233 regions
and you can sort of see here at the
bottom uh how they how they were
distributed uh across patients so so
there is really a mixture in terms of
sort of how how badly damaged
these people's lungs were
here's an example of sort of what one of
those
samples looked like
um
so the first thing we did uh was to sort
of do differential expression
uh so as you can sort of see in the heat
map when you sort of when you line them
up uh sort of uh again you have the
released uh that least damaged on on the
left should do the most damaged on on
the right you can you can clearly see
that there are these
differences in in gene expression
profiles
across here
uh we have when we do
the
statistical testing we find about 4 000
genes uh that are significantly
different uh between uh between these
different states
yes i'm sorry so i don't get lost
so these differences are due
to a
difference in the cell composition or is
differential gene expression within the
same cells
this is
differential gene expression sort of
without the deconvolution so we haven't
done the deconvolution here yet
so this has nothing to do with the
self-tap composition just yet
um
one of these um
the most significantly differentially
regulated genes that came up uh was uh
called it's called serpent e1
and this was a sort of a nice uh
confirmation uh because uh or good good
validation that we're doing something
right because serpent e1
is part of the coagulation pathway where
it's sort of you can see
on the left there it it sort of
inhibitor of these plow and flat genes
which are uh which are sort of important
in in the regulation of fibrinolysis
so
so again coagulation uh is is is sort of
something that that goes wrong in these
patients who have uh have covid
and
so we were able to follow up on this
with rna scope and here again we sort of
we see high expression of serpent e1 uh
in these in these genes so so in in
these samples so so this is sort of a
nice confirmation that we're finding
something which is
uh consistent with the previous
literature
um so
now going back to the sort of cell type
abundance so so here is the result of
the deconvolution
applied to to all of these um
covid samples and as sort of as you can
see here uh we we don't have a huge
difference at least between the sort of
the the least damaged
uh samples uh versus the the more highly
damaged uh on the right
and
you can sort of see that you have you
have differences between the sort of the
the macrophages and the tnn k cells but
other than that it's sort of
relatively homogeneous
in particular if you compare to these
non-covid controls and and here again
you sort of you really see this big
expansion of the
uh of the immune compartment and the
loss of the endothelial cells compare
compared to the covert controls and i
should mention that this is not
immediately obvious that we were going
to get this result uh just because
that's what we saw in the single cell
rna-seq results because it is uh it is
the case that you can often have
different abundances and sometimes you
can have different abundances within the
between the spatial data and the
uh
the dissociated data because some cells
don't handle the dissociation too well
and hence they don't really show up at
the same abundances in the
uh
in the dissociated data as they would in
the in the single cell and in the
spatial data
so we can sort of quantify this here and
again you can sort of see the
differences
uh between the uh between between the
controls and and between and the kovid
and you sort of you see this
you see the big drop in the alveolar
cells
and you big the big increase in the
immune populations as well in the fiber
and the fibroblasts
um what's more interesting perhaps is
that we can now we can break this down
by the uh pathological states and you
can sort of see how um
and this uh how these cell cell
abundances change as the amount of uh as
the amount of damage to the lung
increases now i think what what is
interesting here is that although some
of these
um
states uh you sort of uh cell types you
have a clear progression where you sort
of have uh
sort of uh
more in the in the odad compared to the
present the edad there are also some
states here uh where you sort of where
it seems to be sort of relatively flat
uh and
throughout the disease progression
so
if we so if we put all this together
we can sort of clearly see we can get
this very fine-grained view of how these
cell abundances change in cobit 19. so
so here is sort of trying to summarize
this in in a dot plot where where the so
the size and the color of the dot um
represents the the abundance
of these different cell types uh in the
different pathological states
so but what really makes this
interesting is if you compare this not
just between the different stages of
covid but if you compare it to other
types of lung diseases so here we're
looking at cystic fibrosis and
bronchitis and and this really
highlights the fact that
the sort of the kind of uh
progression of sort of cell type
abundance uh this is in in covid is
quite different from other lung diseases
so obviously you can sort of focus here
you can sort of see that there are some
some cell states there that were sort of
barely see you barely noticed if you if
you hadn't had the
sort of if you had been doing this type
of study in 2019 and you haven't had any
any coded samples to look at
so
in addition to just looking at the the
sort of cell type abundances we also
sort of tried to look at sort of higher
higher level organizations
in terms of uh the cellular organizat
higher level of structures in terms of
the cellular organization so for that we
we employed a non-negative matrix
factorization uh to this um
sort of uh cell abundance by a region of
interest matrix
so so when we do that we get these sort
of cell compartments that effectively
tell you sort of which type of cell
types tend to show up together uh in the
in this analysis
so
so here uh here is sort of uh one uh one
example for for e-dad and sort of you
can sort of see that if you if you look
at the eight different components uh
that that you that we what we chose for
the for the nmf here you can sort of see
that they really sort of group into sort
of five different
sort of uh
sort of sets that that appear to be sort
of
more or less not non-overlapping so so
this is sort of something that we're
still really really organized really
trying to get our head around but but if
you if you do this sort of throughout
the
all the different types of um
uh pathological states you'll see that
these sort of five or or six sort of um
sort of uh super states or niches if you
want to call them they they sort of seem
to be sort of cook uh um sort of
appearing uh relatively stably
throughout which is not super surprising
but there are some important differences
there are some cell states or cell types
that are sort of seem to be
transitioning from sort of one niche to
another as you progress towards the more
severe pathology so again this is sort
of still work in progress we haven't
quite figured out exactly what the what
the significance and how to interpret
this yet
um one of the things that we have made
some more success
has more success around is this issue
about sort of how can we
learn something about the sort of the
severity of the the disease
the the lung damage based on on the gene
expression so so what we did here uh was
uh relatively straightforward so we we
took the the different um
uh
uh
sort of rois the the gene expression
profile for each roi
uh which is sort of each roi would be
associated uh with a
a level of damage and then we asked we
trained a random forest classifier to
try to sort of uh
figure out uh which uh uh given a gene
expression profile which type of damage
do we have here
so uh we did this uh we did this in in
three ways we we did sort of just
picking the
sort of top 1000 most highly variable
genes uh we get an accuracy about 73
percent
uh we also did this sort of using more
restricted uh subsets uh
so for example looking only at uh
surface markers or only at secreted
proteins we get slightly lower uh
accuracy but we still we're still sort
of significantly above chance
what's also interesting is that we can
look at we can look at the so here are
the top 10 genes which are most
um
sort of most informative
for this analysis
and
uh so one thing which is nice is that
also all of them are sort of monotonic
uh so that they're either sort of
highest in ed or higher higher sorry
highest impress or edit or highest in
odad and
sort of we're trying to to figure out if
some of them uh the sort of if there's
any interesting biology here some of
them do seem to make a lot of sense so
this uh cdh11 was recently reported to
be an important regulator for uh
the development of alveolar macrophages
so the fact that it's sort of really
highly expressed in the
severely damaged lungs
really really makes a lot of sense to us
so
uh so really what we're sort of what
we're trying to do here is really to set
up a kind of next generation uh
pathology so we're sort of trying to
combine this sort of uh old-school
histopathology with spatial
transcriptomics and and then sort of use
that to sort of tease out the sort of
the different cell abundances and
the different types of tissue
environments and niches and and then
we're also hoping to be able to sort of
understand more about cell cell
interactions uh using this type of data
uh
analysis is not complete yet so i
haven't been presenting it here but this
is sort of really the sort of
the grand scheme of what we're trying to
achieve here
so uh yeah so with that i'll i'll sort
of sum up uh so we've built this uh
large-scale single-celler and asic atlas
integrated of 15 data sets over 600 000
cells
uh we use this to sort of deconvolute uh
the nanostring data from over 200 rois
from different stages of uh
coven and damaged lungs
and
and that allows us to sort of in
identify the cell abundances and also
sort of gene markers of
pathological states
so finally i'd like to thank my
collaborators this has been work
together with
omar by erector's lab at welcome sanger
institute and michaela noceda at
imperial college london
and the
samples and the sample annotation were
carried out by
researchers at newcastle and york
universities so thank you for your
attention
i might have missed this but the
did you do the nmf on the information
from the undamaged
no so oh no no so the all of the uh
manuscripting data is
from
diseased
uh donors
so
uh they're all very stages of lung
damage okay i'm just trying to get a
feel for what the different factors
might be so you chose eight factors
yes oh yeah yeah i think i think it's
actually it might be different it's
around eight it might be different for
some for some of the different uh
damage states
it's amazing to see the spatial atlas uh
very cool
question
we're looking at
circulating cells athletes and
circulation
age is a factor and then you know
disease duration is a major confounder
in the same severity differentiation
[Music]
so we have tried to sort of correlate
with various metadata features there
aren't really any strong
correlations most likely due to limited
sample size do you have disease duration
information
there is some sort of disease duration
information that was one of the things
that we were interested that we tried to
look at
i think
if i'm trying to remember i think there
was a
very weak signal if we separated them
into sort of
we basically had two bends sort of or
earlier sort of short versus long
duration but
yeah and there was nothing sort of
dramatic that came out of this with
regards to the to
the to the loan profiles
but
it's definitely something that we're
we'll be revisiting now we're trying to
put the paper together i think if you
have a number of days since symptom
onset
treating that as a continuous variable i
think didn't really work
is
um
[Music]
is
yeah that was a great question
i mean like it's definitely something
that one should try i think you probably
need more data to be able to sort of
catch this continuum
uh
so uh yes
so probably probably i i think we're
probably underpowered right now but it
would be it would be great to try
so i was troubled by the fact that
there is
very clear pathological
classification
and on the other hand the sometimes do
not respect it so could it be that
the basis of the pathological
justification is
maybe more global structure of property
because
to the naive eye these four pictures
look very different but somehow it's not
captured by the center
yeah i know it's a great question and
i yeah i don't really have
an answer to that i know that one of
omer's postdocs is sort of
working out
specifically on that and he sort of
i think one of the main things he
discovered was that
within this ed category
that was really sort of ed late versus
ed early and he's
he basically devised this
sort of classifier that separated them
into two different groups and and one of
the so so there's definitely good
evidence that
uh if you do this sort of based more on
the on the molecular data that you would
get slightly different results i'm not
in sort of
hoping to convince pathologists that
it's also sort of better
uh yes this one
so they're not healthy controls right uh
because they're all diseased so so
so yeah so i try to avoid saying healthy
controls i try to say controls
i was also a little bit puzzled by why
there's so much variability
in his signature
let's say the application yeah so yeah
so that's what we would sort of that
would be the last bit right where we're
basically hoping to be able to sort of
say that
we could be able to put forward a panel
that you could use to get it because one
of the interesting things right is that
i think obviously it's a small sampling
but
if you look here so so these are all
disease donors right but if you sort of
see some of them
actually the
don't have so the present ed right so
some of them have
like not a lot of the severe damage so
it is a little bit puzzling but yeah
we're hoping that this could give a
readout to be able to get your readout
on how damaged your wrong is
and what the what the clinicians were
really interested in what they want to
know is of course change sort of
can you tell in advance if someone's
going to start going downhill because
that's one of the big mysteries to them
that they have to have the people in the
icu and then suddenly they
let others recover and they have no idea
why
so
[Applause]
and now we're thinking when